[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente desde casa
en france 24 nuevamente los informes
científicos del panel intergubernamental
sobre cambio climático nos alertan de
las graves consecuencias que traerá
nuestro actual ritmo de vida y de
consumo de recursos naturales la
información más reciente que llegó a
través de un boceto filtrado a la
agencia francesa de noticias afp afirma
que la extinción de especies el colapso
de ecosistemas las olas de calor extremo
y otros impactos severos causados por el
cambio climático están acelerando se
tanto que lo peor está por venir según
el reporte los bebés nacidos este año
sufrirán los efectos devastadores de
estos cambios cuando estén en su
treintena algo que según la organización
independiente climate central dice mucho
de nosotros como predecesores
nuestros esfuerzos para parar el cambio
climático
sí
fechas sirven tanto para proteger las
vidas que tenemos ahora como para
delinear las historias que nuestros
descendientes cuenten de nosotros
y creo que habrá muchas historias sobre
lo que perdimos
sobre las cosas que no supimos proteger
y pensar que algunas de las cosas que no
podremos proteger son varias de las
ciudades costeras del mundo vivir en la
costa o en las riberas o deltas de los
ríos ha sido históricamente un aliciente
económico comercial turístico o
puramente personal sin embargo muchos de
los asentamientos serán inhabitables en
un futuro cercano el aumento del nivel
del mar causado por el calentamiento
global pone en peligro el hogar de
cientos de millones de habitantes según
el reporte provisional del ipcc esto
hará que haya que tomar decisiones
difíciles ya que la subida en los
niveles y en la temperatura del agua
incrementa la intensidad y frecuencia de
tormentas e inundaciones y también de
las olas de calor y los lugares que más
van a sufrir el embate de estas serán
las islas y los lugares que se
encuentran en los litorales hay ejemplos
en todos los continentes
tokio nueva york miami dhaka en
bangladesh ciudad del cabo o venecia de
hecho una décima parte de la población
mundial vive en lugares que están a sólo
diez metros por encima del nivel del mar
muchas de nuestras ciudades
son mortales
a largo plazo muchas de ellas dejarán de
existir por una inundación
aquí en 2050 eso ya será mucho más
visible
la ciudad italiana es una de las que más
está sufriendo las altas mareas el 90%
de venecia es vulnerable ante las
inundaciones de inundación y visto como
el nivel medio del mar está aumentando
las inundaciones son más frecuentes en
frecuencia solíamos tener dos o tres al
año extra fuerte el año pasado tuvimos
en un aumento de 50 centímetros sería
catastrófico para venecia porque
tendríamos una media del nivel del mar
de 82 centímetros encima de medio tanto
túnez centímetro la plaza de san marcos
está a 80 centímetros sobre el nivel del
mar lo que significa que tendríamos agua
en la plaza de san marcos todo el tiempo
y si las peores predicciones se cumplen
en 80 años el nivel del mar subiría 1,1
metros aunque pueda parecer muy
alarmante o pesimista el informe da
cabida a la esperanza dando algunas
ideas ya conocidas de cómo evitar las
peores consecuencias y prepararse para
las que ya son inevitables entre otras
están la conservación y restauración de
manglares pastos marinos y arrecifes de
coral que ayudarán a mantener a raya a
algunos de los impactos de huracanes y
tormentas también la construcción de
diques y rompeolas que ayudan a reducir
el riesgo de inundación aunque puedan
suponer la destrucción de ecosistemas y
por supuesto reducir la cantidad de
emisiones al mínimo sin embargo hay que
tener en cuenta que la acumulación de
gases de efecto invernadero presente
ahora mismo la atmósfera ya será
responsable del aumento del nivel del
mar de aquí a 2050 y no hay nada que
podamos hacer al respecto para la joven
activista sueca greta tan ver el reporte
es una manera de hacer que la gente se
dé cuenta de la situación en la que
estamos
esta canción es corto y huber in you
confirma lo que ya sabíamos que la
situación es muy grave y que tenemos que
actuar ahora mismo pero siento que se
espera
porque por lo menos mucha más gente está
siendo capaz de decir las cosas como son
no podemos enfrentar esta crisis si no
la tratamos como tales salvo que seamos
lo suficientemente adultos como para
decir la verdad y enfrentarnos a la
realidad así que creo que esto podría
llevar a que mucha gente despierte y
esto es muy esperanza son saint marc
webb y polop pero lo más importante es
actuar y hacerlo cuanto antes
antes que nada creo que hay que empezar
puedes hablar de políticas todo el
tiempo pero hay que actuar y hay que
hacerlo ahora porque ya estamos llegando
demasiado tarde intenten hacer cosas
pero también aprendan unos de los otros
nosotros aprendimos mucho de singapur y
singapur de nosotros así que realmente
tenemos que trabajar juntos para
resolver este problema el informe final
no estará listo hasta febrero de 2022
una fecha que llegará después de la
cumbre sobre biodiversidad en china-
agendada para octubre y de la de cambio
climático prevista para noviembre en
glasgow algo que muchos científicos
lamentan como una oportunidad perdida de
meter presión a gobiernos y legisladores
es todo por esta semana recuerden que
pueden volver a ver todas las emisiones
de medio ambiente en la sección de
programas de nuestro sitio web france24
puntocom
[Música]